Oh, okay. So, like, yeah, it makes
sense. Um, last question if it's okay. I
know you got a lot of know it's your
world, man. Because you're Greek. Oh,
thanks. Um, so I was talking to I think
it's some like I don't even know what he
is, but I I just non-denominational for
now. But I was talking to him about
communion, and he brought up the
objection about you can't drink blood.
So, he was telling me you can't drink
blood. Like in Old Testament laws, whose
blood can't you drink? Well, I thought
it was always the blood of animals, but
he was like, "No, blood is blood." No,
that's not true. He's like, "Yeah, I
that's what I told him." But you cannot
drink the blood of the animal. And that
makes sense. Why? Because it takes life.
The blood is the soul, the life of the
victim, right? Yeah. So when you drink
the blood of the animal, you're drinking
the life of the animal, right? Yeah.
But the animal cannot preserve your life
because the animal is inferior to you in
value in the sight of God. Correct.
Yeah. Who has greater value and dignity
in the sight of God?
The human. Human. So why do you think
animal sacrifices had to be repeated
over and over again?
It was atonement. There wasn't an
eternal to be repeated over and over
again. There wasn't an infinite like
eternal sacrifice
because an
animal life is not equal to a human
life. Oh yeah. It's inferior in value,
right? Yeah. That makes much more sense.
So how can an animal life justify and
satisfy as a payment for human life?
Because the soul that sin shall die,
right? Mhm. So how can an animal life,
animal soul be adequate payment for a
human soul? It cannot correct. Yeah, it
can't. So what happens is because the
animals could
not be a sufficient adequate payment for
a human soul that sin, they would be
repeated as a sign to God that a death
takes place when someone sins. So either
you die or someone else dies in your
place to spare you from dying. So in
this case the animals but the animals
are not adequate enough sufficient
enough to provide an adequate payment to
make satisfaction for a human
death right because it's inferior. So
God had them repeat it to provide a
temporary covering and therefore when
you take in the blood of an animal
you're taking in the life of that animal
right? Yeah. But an animal's life is
inferior to your life. Yeah. So what
would be the point of taking in the
animal life? There wouldn't be a point.
It just be stupid. For the life of the
flesh, Leviticus 17:11. Mhm. The soul of
the flesh is in the blood. And I've
given it to you on the altar to make
atonement for your souls. For it is the
blood that makes atonement by the life.
So this is the context of
not eating blood. Here it is. What's the
context? Because when you eat blood,
you're eating the soul, the life of the
victim.
Yeah. So, do you understand the
connection? Yeah. Yeah, I do. I see it.
You guys in the comment section, you're
learning or are you engaging? So, I
start blocking people because the
questions for me to answer is for your
benefit. That's why I'm doing it live.
He just asked the question. You're not
supposed to eat blood. Then why are you
eating the flesh drinking and blood of
the Lord? Here's the argument. What God
is saying is you are not to eat animal
blood because that's the only blood that
you could shed. Oh yeah. Because the
life of the flesh is in the blood.
Right. So if I were to eat the blood of
the animal, I'm doing what? Eating the
life, the soul of the animal. Right.
Mhm. But why would I want to take in the
life the soul of the animal when human
soul is greater than an animal soul?
Right. Yeah. It doesn't make any sense.
When I drink the blood of Jesus, what am
I taking in? His life. And isn't that
the life of the God man? Yeah. It's much
better. And if anyone's life you want in
you is his life, right? Mhm. So that
makes sense why we would eat his flesh
and drink his blood because we are
taking his life in us and then his life
becomes our life and his life is
incorruptible. So we become
incorruptible. Oh, so that's why he says
that in John six. Yeah. Oh, okay. that.
Yeah, it was a much much better answer
than I gave him, but that makes much
more sense. All right. Well, um I know
you got a lot of people in here. H Yeah,
it definitely does help me. Yeah. All
right, brother. Yeah. All right. I'm
going to try to talk to Father when I'm
in California. Yeah. Find them. Yeah.
And tell him that you know Sam Shimon.
Maybe then he's going to get you blocked
from going to church. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Hopefully not. I might I probably won't
tell him that if it happens, but yeah,
I'll come back in um when I do. All
right, brother. God bless you. Thank
you. Have a good one. Come bless. Do you
see now the wisdom and the logic in why
you don't eat the blood of the animal?
Because you're eating the life of the
animal. You're ingesting the animal's
life. So the animal's life becomes your
life. Right? Why? Animal souls, animal
lives are inferior to human lives. But
when you take in the flesh of the God
man and drink the blood of the God man,
you're taking in the life of the God man
and his life is
incorruptible. Right?